merci nous accordé cette entrevue c'est
un grand plaisir
alors pourquoi évidemment la question
c'est tellement rare pourquoi cet
engagement à vie avec l'orchestré
métropolitain
notre histoire est unique c'est rare que
nos orchestres fait confiance à un chef
à l'âge de 25 ans pour ces destinée
artistique alors déjà ça c'était unique
et si surtout unique que vingt ans plus
tard on sème encore plus qu'au début et
je pense que c'est une façon pour moi
comme pour l' orchestre de rendre
hommage à cette confiance mutuelle et de
d'enlever cette espèce de barrières du
temps qui est toujours là parce que on
se demande tout le temps et d'amante
loin oui c'est ça qui dit ah oui mais
yannick ça va bien le jour il va s'en
aller ou moi je me disais abandonnés ils
vont peut-être être tanné ils vont
vouloir avoir quelqu'un d'autre
[Musique]
plus haut au lieu où on se dit non on on
s'aime on fait de la grande musique
ensemble nos projets sont beaux alors on
se donne encore plus de liberté pour
l'avenir pense
en unissant nos destinées comme ça
qu'est ce que ça change au fond sur le
plan musical pour l'orc est sur le plan
artistique
ça peut changer artistiquement parce que
tout le monde sait à quoi s'en tenir il
ya plus une question de si je fais ceci
peut-être que yani qui nous aimerons
plus bien thomas geve des musiciens qui
me disait ça quelques années en toi
maintenant tu diriges home est vérifiée
à des filles en tu nous aimes europe et
une trouve au plus beau que moi je les
avais beau leur dire à chaque fois non
ça c'est pas comme ça que ça se passe je
vous trouve merveilleux et puis je vois
de plus je plus je voyage puis je
comprends l'unicité aussi du seul
orchestre metropolit est donc c'est une
façon vraiment se donner cette liberté
c'est-à-dire de grandir ensemble encore
plus il parle et d'unicité parce que
c'est vrai vous êtes maintenant au home
est vous êtes à philadelphie vous
vous êtes une superstar caisse ou est-ce
que se situe l'om pour vous dans ce
palmarès là c'est un orchestre qui
jeunes parce que bon on fête les 40 ans
l'année prochaine de leurs caisses
c'est très jeune par rapport à d'autres
institutions philadephie ça fait presque
120 ans le met aussi donc c'est sûr
qu'on parle pas de la même chose au
niveau de la notoriété historique mais
au niveau du son ce que ça donne c'est
un orchestre qui a été déjà fondé dès
les années 80 avec cette chose
visionnaire qui était d'incorporer la
l'éducation le fait d'aller vers les
gens le fait d'avoir des valeurs de
proximité d'accessibilité tout en
gardant le cap sur l'excellence en
musique
alors ça c'est c'est être
révolutionnaire dans les années 80 parce
que en général les orchestres voulait se
tenir loin de ça l'éducation c'était
pour d'autres cantons jouer dans un
orchestre il fallait qu'on soit déjà les
gens qui viennent nous entende et devait
tout connaître
alors que nous y voilà mais aujourd'hui
tout le monde parle de cette
démocratisation
mais leur quête métropolitain finalement
ils ont beaucoup de longueurs d'avancé
parce que c'était dans sa mission et je
pense que ça sa teinte le son est
l'attitude musicale des musiciens et
messieurs se donne à 200 pour ça qu'on
joue dans un sous sol dans un
arrondissement de montréal qu'on joue
dans une église qu on joue dans une
acoustique très sèche ou qu'on joue en
europe ou au carnegie hall
comme ce sera le cas bientôt en novembre
qu'on joue à notre belle maison
symphonique est donc cette décision a
été prise en europe en fait après votre
grande tournée européenne
[Musique]
rien qui me préparais qui nous préparer
à ce succès fantastique dans les plus
grandes salles du monde avec un public
qui en a vu passer beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup et qui qui disait des choses
aussi dithyrambique que maintenant alors
qu'est-ce que trop politesse et le
nouveau jalon par lequel on va juger les
autres orchestres
[Musique]
je me suis dit alors qu'il me donne
tellement tout est encore plus que ce
que j'aurais souhaité
j'ai envie de continuer avec eux toute
ma vie est-ce que ça va aider leurs
caisses pour le financement public pour
la classe de leur caisse métropolitain
montréal on si vous avez tellement
difficultés pour vous en avez encore
pour répéter ou pour avoir accès à la
maison symphonique
qu'est ce que ça change à ce niveau là
où est ce que ça change quelque chose
c'est une décision qui a des
répercussions stratégique
alors oui nos partenaires qu'ils soient
gouvernementaux qui soit aussi de du
monde des affaires
souvent venez avec la question mais
c'est bien beau de l'histoire mécanique
mais il ya n'est qu'un jour vos quitté
et il y avait cette incertitude qui est
outre avait parfois si certaines
personnes qui avaient envie d'investir
plus de ressources dans leurs caisses
métropolitain alors c'est sûr que ça va
changer ça va donner aussi je parle de
juste une plus grande reconnaissance
lorsqu'on est à la table et qu'on peut
parler de comment on peut partager le
temps la maison symphonique c'est notre
souhait il ya des discussions là-dessus
vous avez déjà dit on sent un peu comme
des touristes c'est quand même
incroyable oui c'est quand même
incroyable en fait ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que avec le niveau
qu'on a atteint c'est un peu comme un
athlète olympique si on pas les
ressources ou les endroits pour
s'entraîner c'est sûr qu'ils vont pas
gagner aux olympiques ça c'est quelque
chose qu'on comprend donc répéter dans
des conditions acoustiques acceptable
c'est intimement lié à aux résultats
musicale qu'on veut obtenir
[Musique]
on
et c'est pour ça que c'est important que
nous aussi on y soit mais ce que je
trouve beau dans ce message c'est que on
ressent beaucoup d'amour des montréalais
est ce que je trouve unique de montréal
peluche voyage à l'extérieur à
l'étranger c'est que c'est pas une ville
comme les autres culturellement on le
dit depuis des années mais c'est une
ville qui a une richesse culturelle une
variété de l'offre une richesse de
l'offre culturelle les festivals
tellement de festival et personne ne se
pose la question si il devrait y avoir
que le tnm mais non on a le rideau vert
pour le centhor puis on a le du cep et
j'en passe quat'sous et tout ça donc
c'est sûr que deux internationaux mais
qui sont aussi pour la communauté et on
a notre personnalité notre histoire
différente et en cohabiter on voit
maintenant qu'il ya de la place pour ça
et c'est ce qui me rend très fier dit la
bce on veut juste notre juste place est
ce que ça veut dire que ça met fin
complètement à la possibilité que vous
facile chaud alors que cela phonique
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui sont
dit quand kent nagano a annoncé qu'il
partait que peut-être que ça serait pour
vous en faites par fait ma famille c'est
leur caisse métropolitain on a une
histoire qui est assez unique dans le
monde et qui a fait en sorte que on
s'est trouvés on sait garder et je
respecte beaucoup alors que symphonique
de montréal et je leur souhaite de
trouver la meilleure personne pour être
à leur tête mais moi mon histoire ici
est avec leur caisse métropolitain et
effectivement c'est c'est une façon
entre autres cette annonce de marquer
que deux ma place à montréal c'est leur
4e producteur estime okuyama galipeau